This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Armato is always read the plaque. It's always worth stopping to see what person or event is being commemorated in stone and metal. The person being depicted is not always worthy. The story being told is not always true. Plaques often tell you more about the person who commissioned them than the historical figure that they are honoring. It's still worth always reading the plaque, but it's not enough to just read the plaque. If I'd denominator one person to write all the plaques in the world, my choice would be Nate Dimeo of the Memory Palace. He produced an episode about a statue and an imagined plaque in 2015 that just destroys me. It's so good. I've been thinking about it a lot recently,
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。阿马托总是在阅读铭牌。驻足观看什么人或什么事件正被刻在石碑和金属上，总是值得的。被描绘的人并非都值得纪念。所讲述的故事并非都是真的。铭牌往往比它们所纪念的历史人物，更能告诉你关于委托制作它们的人的信息。阅读铭牌依然有价值，但仅仅阅读铭牌是不够的。如果让我指定一个人来写世界上所有的铭牌，我的选择将是《记忆宫殿》的内特·迪梅奥。他在2015年制作了一集关于一座雕像和一个想象中铭牌的节目，深深震撼了我。它太棒了。我最近一直在思考它，
and I want you to hear it. Notes on an Imagine plaque to be added to the Statue of General Nathan Bedford Forest upon hearing that the Memphis City Council is voted to move it, and the Exume remains of General Forest and his wife, Mary Ann Montgomery Forest, from their current location in a park downtown to the nearby Elmwood cemetery. First, it should be big, the plaque. Not necessarily because there's so much to say, though there is so much to say, but big enough to be noticed on the side of this rather grand monument, after they move it and the bodies beneath it, across town to the cemetery.
我想让你听听它。关于一块想象中铭牌的笔记，这块铭牌将被添加到内森·贝德福德·福斯特将军的雕像上，此前听说孟菲斯市议会投票决定将其搬迁，并将福斯特将军及其妻子玛丽·安·蒙哥马利·福斯特的遗骸，从他们目前在市中心公园的位置迁至附近的埃尔姆伍德公墓。首先，这个铭牌应该很大。不一定是因为有那么多话要说，尽管确实有很多话要说，但要大到足以在这个相当宏伟的纪念碑侧面引人注目，在他们把它和它下方的遗体一起搬过整个城市到公墓之后。
And not just big for the sake of bigness, it needs to stick out as something off, something that disrupts the admirable balance of the statue, currently so tasteful, wriggle even, this bronze man on this bronze horse, go tea, square jaw, you get it. You've seen it before, even if you haven't seen it before. The statue faces North. The sculptor wanted for us to face South, to better catch the light, but people complained. Said it would imply that the general was retreating, and he wasn't a man who retreated. He surrendered once, but if the sculpture face North, maybe people would forget that part,
而且不仅仅是为了大而大，它需要显得格格不入，某种打破雕像令人钦佩平衡的东西，目前它是如此高雅，甚至可以说是华丽，这个青铜马上的青铜男人，茶色，方下巴，你懂的。你以前见过，即使你以前没见过。雕像面朝北方。雕塑原本希望我们面朝南方，以便更好地捕捉光线，但人们抱怨了。说这意味着将军在撤退，而他不是一个会撤退的人。他投降过一次，但如果雕塑面朝北方，也许人们会忘记那部分，
I guess. So ending with the plaque has to be big enough to catch your eye when you're checking your cell phone or walking your dog or eating a chicken Caesar salad from a plastic box in a bench. Whatever people are doing there in the cemetery. And whatever they might do there in the future, because that's why we make these things, right? Placks, bronze men on bronze horses. We want people in the future to remember. But first we want them to notice. So let's think about material for this imagined black.
我想是这样。因此，最后这个铭牌必须足够大，当你检查手机、遛狗或从塑料盒里吃着鸡肉凯撒沙拉坐在长椅上时，能吸引你的眼球。无论人们在公墓里做什么。无论他们将来在那里做什么，因为这就是我们制作这些东西的原因，对吧？铭牌，青铜马上的青铜男人。我们希望未来的人们能够记住。但首先我们希望他们注意到。所以让我们考虑一下这个想象中铭牌的材质。
Maybe the black should be garish, not intentionally ugly, not necessarily, but like titanium maybe. A patch of Frank Geary Futurism on the stage, stately old thing. It would catch the light and catch the eye. In contrast to the northward facing brown green man on his brown green horse, or a great pigeon, a lit on his brown green epilet.
也许这个铭牌应该非常显眼，不一定是故意做得很丑，但也许像钛一样。在这个庄严古老的事物上的一片弗兰克·盖里式的未来主义。它会捕捉光线，吸引目光。与那个面朝北方的棕绿色男人和他的棕绿色马形成对比，或者一只大鸽子落在他棕绿色的肩章上。
And I like that the Geary of it all, the Futurism, is not at all futuristic, it's millennial. A decade from now it'll be dated, literally dated. Bill Bauer, Disney Hall, or wherever will seem so late 90s, so 2000s. He'll scoff, and I want that. I want this plaque to be fixed in time, to let people know when it went up, let people know what was up at the time. Because that is the point here. The point of this plaque is to make sure that these future people realize that this lovely old statue wasn't always old
我喜欢盖里的这种风格，这种未来主义一点也不未来主义，它是千禧年代的。从现在起十年后，它会显得过时，字面意义上的过时。比尔·鲍尔、迪士尼音乐厅或其他什么地方会显得那么带有90年代后期和2000年代的色彩。人们会嘲笑它，而我想要的就是这个。我希望这个铭牌被固定在时间中，让人们知道它是何时竖起的，让人们知道当时发生了什么。因为这才是重点。这个铭牌的重点是确保未来的人们意识到这个可爱古老的雕像并不总是那么古老，
and wasn't always here in the cemetery. And moreover, I want the reader standing there in the shadow cast by the late, somehow still lamented, Nathan Bedford Forest on some future summer Sunday, to know why it wound up in a park in the other side of town in the first place. Because memorials aren't memories, they don't just appear upon death, a letter of surrender
而且并不总是在这里的公墓里。此外，我希望站在某个未来夏日周日里，由已故的、某种程度上依然令人怀念的内森·贝德福德·福斯特投下的阴影中的读者，明白为什么它最初会最终出现在城另一边的公园里。因为纪念碑不是记忆，它们不会在死亡或在某个战场边缘的农舍里签署的降书之后自然出现。
signed in some farmhouse at the edge of some battlefield. It doesn't come complete with a historic marker affixed to the door. The monument to Nathan Bedford Forest was put in that park downtown for a reason, at a specific moment in time. And at that time, General Forest and Mrs. Forest were already buried in Elmwood Cemetery. The same place the city council recently voted to put them. His body and her body were originally dug up from the ground because a group of prominent memphians thought they were better off somewhere else. That was 1905, 40 years after the war, 30 years after Forest's death, they felt the city needed Nathan Bedford Forest right then, because they had seen that city fall from Great Heights.
它不会附带一个固定在门上的历史标记。内森·贝德福德·福斯特的纪念碑之所以被放在市中心的那个公园里是有原因的，是在一个特定的历史时刻。而在那个时候，福斯特将军和福斯特夫人已经埋葬在埃尔姆伍德公墓了。也就是市议会最近投票决定将他们放回的地方。他的遗体和她的遗体最初是从地下被挖出来的，因为一群孟菲斯的名流认为他们在别处会过得更好。那是1905年，战争结束40年后，福斯特去世30年后，他们觉得城市当时迫切需要内森·贝德福德·福斯特，因为他们看到这座城市从顶峰跌落。
Memphis had been left relatively unscathed by the war, but not by its outcome. Not by the end of the slave trade, that had been one of the economic and cultural pillars of the city. Without the slave market selling men and women and children, without the river boats and crews and suppliers and dock workers sending them up and down the river, Memphis was hardly Memphis anymore. And then there was the yellow fever that had swept through the city some years before and killed so many. And drove many more away, people who never returned after a mandatory evacuation. And now it was the turn of the next century. And the city was increasingly, let's just say it, let's just stop not saying things. Increasingly black. And increasingly tense. White businesses
孟菲斯在战争中受到的破坏相对较小，但其结局并非如此。奴隶贸易的终结对它产生了巨大影响，奴隶贸易曾是该市的经济和文化支柱之一。没有了买卖男人、女人和儿童的奴隶市场，没有了运送他们顺流而下的河船、船员、供应商和码头工人，孟菲斯就不再是原来的孟菲斯了。接着是几年前席卷全城并夺走无数生命的黄热病。并且迫使更多人在强制疏散后选择离开，再也没有回来。现在轮到下一个世纪了。而这座城市越来越，我们直说吧，不再避讳了。越来越黑人化。而且越来越紧张。白人企业
did not like competing with black businesses. Black people did not like being lynched. This move to move forest started not long after Ida B. Wells, a Memphian too, had started writing, rabble rousing, boldly, bravely, against lynching. After her friend Thomas Moss was improperly imprisoned, after a fight between children over a game of marbles escalated until adults were threatening to burn down his store, and after Moss wound up being pulled from that prison and strung from a tree, and Wells was threatened so much so often that she moved away, and the paper she had written for burned to the ground. away, and the paper she had written for burned to the ground. So wealthy white Memphis, at the beginning of the 1900s, found all of this unpleasant.
不喜欢与黑人企业竞争。黑人不喜欢被私刑处决。这场关于搬迁福斯特雕像的运动，在同为孟菲斯人的埃达·B·韦尔斯开始大胆、勇敢地撰文反对私刑后不久就开始了。在她的朋友托马斯·莫斯被不公正地关押之后，在孩子们为弹珠游戏发生争执导致成年人威胁要烧毁他的商店之后，在莫斯被从监狱拉出来并吊死在树上之后，韦尔斯受到了如此频繁的威胁以至于她搬走了，她曾为其撰稿的报纸也被烧毁了。因此，20世纪初富裕的白人孟菲斯人发现这一切都令人不快。
So they raised money, $33,000, not to rebuild that newspaper office, or build a police force that would properly protect all of its citizens, but to make a monument to a man they thought best represented a Memphis they had lost. A man who had risen from nothing, a blacksmith's boy, who became a millionaire, and then believed so strongly in the Confederate cause that he enlisted as a private, then went on to prove himself perhaps the most brilliant military man, born on American soil, even if he didn't fight for America. Those are facts.
因此，他们筹集了33,000美元，不是用来重建那家报社，也不是用来建立能够充分保护所有公民的警察部队，而是为他们认为最能代表他们已经失去的孟菲斯的那个男人建造一座纪念碑。一个白手起家、铁匠的儿子，后来成为百万年薪的人，并对邦联事业坚信不疑以至于作为列兵参军，随后证明了自己或许是美国本土诞生的最杰出的军事天才，即使他并不是为美国而战。这些都是事实。
That's a true story. And they like what this story said about the American dream. Even if it wasn't technically American. Even if Forrest's million was made by buying and selling human beings, and selling cotton raised and picked and cleaned and packed by enslaved human beings, even if the cause for which he employed that military genius was to ensure that men like him could rise up from nothing and make a million dollars, buying and selling human beings, and stealing their lives in their labor. In 1905, they held a parade at the unveiling of the new statue and made speeches to honor
这是一个真实的故事。他们喜欢这个故事所传达的美国梦。即使它在技术上并非美国式的。即使福斯特的百万财富是通过买卖人类，以及销售由被奴役的人类种植、采摘、清理和打包的棉花赚来的，即使他运用这种军事天才的事业是为了确保像他这样的人能够白手起家并赚到一百万，通过买卖人类，掠夺他们的生命和劳动。1905年，他们在揭幕新雕像时举行了游行，并发表了演讲来纪念
the northward facing general. They said nothing of slavery. They said much about heritage, and honor, and chivalry. They said nothing of how Nathan Bedford forest had been the first grand wizard of the Ku Klux Klan. Nothing of the terror it had wrought. Nothing of the assassinations, or the lynchings. Nothing of how it sought to undermine and overthrow the nation's political order. The nation that they celebrated there in Memphis in 1905, when they played the star-spangled banner in Yankee-Doodle-Dandy, right alongside Dixie. They might not have mentioned any of it, but they knew it. New about forest in the clan.
这位面朝北方的将军。他们对奴隶制闭口不谈。他们大谈特谈传统、荣誉和骑士精神。他们没有提内森·贝德福德·福斯特曾是三K党的第一任最高大巫师。没有提它造成的恐怖。没有提暗杀或私刑。没有提它如何试图破坏和推翻国家的政治秩序。他们在1905年的孟菲斯庆祝的那个国家，当他们在演奏《星条旗》和《扬基歌》的同时，也播放着《迪ie》。他们可能没有提及这一切，但他们心里清楚。了解福斯特和三K党。
They certainly read the clansmen. It was flying off the shelves that year, a novel about heroic men hidden beneath bedsheets, out to save white virtue from black barbarians. It was a historical romance that's how it built itself that looked back long and lee to a time not long before, when people were still chivalrous, who'd stand up against barbarism, when people were still chivalrous, who'd stand up against barbarism and miscegenation, and instability, and stand up for order, private property. Who better to represent what they had lost than Nathan Bedford Forest? They talked about his heroism in battle, though they didn't talk about the battle of Fort Pillo, when forest ordered the massacre
他们当然读过三K党人的作品。那一年这本书卖得火热，这是一部关于隐藏在床单下的英雄男人的小说，旨在从黑人野蛮人手中拯救白人的美德。这是一部历史传奇——它是这样宣传自己的——它长久地回顾了不久前人们仍然具有骑士精神、敢于挺身而出反对野蛮行径、反对种族混血和不稳定、并为秩序和私有财产挺身而出的时代。还有谁比内森·贝德福德·福斯特更能代表他们所失去的一切呢？他们谈论他在战斗中的英雄气概，尽管他们没有谈论皮罗堡战役，当时福斯特下令屠杀
of hundreds of American troops, attempting to surrender. Most of them former slaves. They talked about his faith instead, his strapping build, and about their own hopes, that future memphians would gaze upon Nathan Bedford Forest, and be inspired. They even raised some extra cash for a skating rink, so that the white children of Memphis could play nearby, and the shadow of this great man, and learn from his shining example, though the bronze wouldn't shine for long, would brown and green as the symbol of all that was good was exposed to the light of the sun and washed by the rain.
数百名试图投降的美国士兵。其中大多数是前奴隶。相反，他们谈论他的信仰、他健壮的体格，以及他们自己的愿望，即未来的孟菲斯人会凝视内森·贝德福德·福斯特并受到启发。他们甚至为溜冰场筹集了一些额外的资金，以便孟菲斯白人儿童可以在附近玩耍，在这个伟人的阴影下，并从他光辉的榜样中学习，尽管青铜不会永远闪亮，随着象征一切美好的事物暴露在阳光下并经受雨水洗刷，它会变成棕色和绿色。
There is debate, there is always debate, about what the clan meant when Forrest was its wizard, about his intentions at Fort Pillow. They say Forrest repented his sins and his crimes and his deathbed. Should that be on the plaque? Should it note his regret? I say no. May it have ruined him. May it have corroded him, like rain on bronze. May it have choked him, like smoke from the crosses, and homes and churches burnt by men who revered him decades and decades later, revered him at least in part, because some influential Memphians decided they needed to revere him in this way,
一直以来都有关于福斯特担任大巫师时三K党意味着什么以及他在皮罗堡的意图的辩论。据说福斯特在临终前忏悔了自己的罪孽和罪行。这应该写在铭牌上吗？它应该记录他的悔意吗？我说不。愿它毁了他。愿它侵蚀他，就像雨水侵蚀青铜一样。愿它窒息他，就像几十年前崇拜他的人点燃的十字架、房屋和教堂冒出的浓烟一样，他们崇拜他至少部分是因为一些有影响力的孟菲斯人决定他们需要以这种方式崇拜他，
in that park, in 1905. So the plaque should be big, but it can't be big enough to say all that. Maybe it should just say, maybe they should all say, the many, many thousands of Confederate memorials and monuments and markers, that the men who fought and died for the CSA, whatever their personal reasons, whatever was in their hearts, did so on behalf of a government formed for the express purpose of ensuring that men and women and children could be bought and sold and
在1905年的那个公园里。所以铭牌应该很大，但它不可能大到足以表达所有这些。也许它应该只说，也许所有的数千座邦联纪念碑、雕像和标记都应该说，那些为南方邦联战斗并牺牲的人，无论他们的个人原因是什么，无论他们内心如何，都是代表一个明确为了确保男人、女人和儿童可以被买卖和毁灭的政府而战的。也许这就足够了。但我希望人们了解1905年那些希望人们记住福斯特以及原因的孟菲斯人。那些想要一个可以高高举起并崇拜的象征，来代表他们最珍视之物的人。我希望人们知道这座雕像在孟菲斯市中心矗立了110年。并记住纪念碑不是记忆，它们有动机，它们具有历史性，但它们本身并不是历史。我希望他们知道它为什么被搬迁。那就是在2015年，在克莱门特·平克尼、舒兰达·科尔曼·辛格尔顿、泰温扎·桑德斯、埃塞尔·兰斯、苏西·杰克逊、辛西娅·赫德、迈拉·汤普森和丹尼尔
destroyed it will. Maybe that should be enough. But I want people to know about those Memphians in 1905 who wanted people to remember for us and why. Who wanted a symbol to hold up and revere, to stand for what they valued most. I want people to know that that statue stood in downtown Memphis for 110 years. And to remember that memorials aren't memories, they have motives, they are historical, they are not history itself. And I want them to know why it was moved. That in 2015, after a clement to Pinkney and Shuranda Coleman singleton, and Tywanza Sanders and Ethel Lance and Suzie Jackson and Cynthia Heard and Myra Thompson and Daniel
西蒙斯Sr.以及佩恩·米ド尔顿·多クター在南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿的一座教堂里被谋杀之后。孟菲斯有很多人在南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿的一座教堂里。孟菲斯有些人已经厌倦了符号，准备彻底埋葬内森·贝德福德·福斯特。2016年，田纳西州历史委员会最终拒绝了孟菲斯市议会从公园移走内森·贝德福德·福斯特雕像的计划。截至2017年8月，它仍然在那里。弗吉尼亚州夏洛茨维尔的事件导致了在雕像旁边的抗议活动，
Simmons Sr. and to Payne Middleton Doctor were murdered in a church in Charleston, South Carolina. There were people in Memphis church in Charleston, South Carolina. There were people in Memphis who were done with symbols, and ready to bury Nathan Bedford Forest for good. In 2016, the Tennessee Historical Commission ended up denying the Memphis City Council's plan to move the Nathan Bedford Forest statue from the park. It's still there, as of August 2017. The events in Charlottesville, Virginia have resulted in protests at the side of the statue
公众和市官员再次呼吁拆除这座纪念碑。《记忆宫殿》由内特·戴梅奥制作。你应该订阅它并收听所有旧节目。它们很短，文笔优美，制作精良，就我而言，这就是播客被发明出来的原因。我们节目的工作人员包括凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫莱门特、谢里夫·乌斯、肖恩·里亚尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、德兰尼·霍尔、埃米斯·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎以及我罗曼·马尔斯。
and renewed calls by the public and city officials to have the monument removed. The memory palace is produced by Nate D'Ameo. You should subscribe to it and get all the old episodes. They're short, they're beautifully written and produced, and they're what podcasting was invented for as far as I'm concerned. The staff of our show includes Katie Mingle, Avery Trufflement, Sharifuse of, Sean Rial, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall, Emmith Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的“无线电街”制作。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，或在 99PI Orc 上@该节目，也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但我们在互联网上可爱的家，拥有比我们在这里能告诉你的更多的设计故事，是我们的网站。网址是 99PI.org。
We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc or on Instagram Tumblr and Reddit too. But our lovely home on the internet with more design stories than we can ever tell you here is our website. It's 99PI.org.
我们的。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Our ex. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.